continúan las deliberaciones en el
congreso peruano luego de que por
segunda vez el hemiciclo rechazar el
adelanto de las elecciones de abril de
2024 con 68 votos en contra 54 a favor y
dos abstenciones el proyecto de ley fue
bloqueado señores congresistas el
proyecto de reforma constitucional no ha
alcanzado el número de votos previsto en
el artículo dos cero seis de la
Constitución para su aprobación
sin embargo el pleno peruano accedió a
debatirlo nuevamente Pero esta vez
incluirá a la asamblea Constituyente una
consulta popular para definirse los
peruanos quieren una nueva constitución
este es uno de los pedidos de la
izquierda que fue asunto de la campaña
de Pedro castillo y que ha polarizado la
opinión ciudadana porque lo que queremos
sí irnos pero convencidos como le vuelvo
a repetir que si no cambiamos o ponemos
siquiera los primeros pasos para una
nueva constitución que eso implica un
referendo preguntarle al pueblo
no quiere una nueva constitución por eso
vamos a votar en contra nosotros le
tienen miedo a la asamblea Constituyente
Claro que le tienen miedo porque se
diseñaría un nuevo concepto de país
mucho más humano la actual situación de
Perú ha generado levantamientos contra
la presidenta Dina boluarte
desencadenando fuertes hechos de
violencia que dejaron un saldo de más de
medio centenar de muertos por los
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
las fuerzas de seguridad